i'm just so used to being attacked for
everything i say
it's like at this point i'm like all
right you know what what are you gonna
do you're gonna call me a mean name
what would that feel like what would it
feel like to see myself called something
horrible in every newspaper
in the country oh wait i've done that
i'm dave rubin and this is the reuben
report as always guys make sure you're
subscribed to our channel
and re-subscribe when youtube
unsubscribes you and joining me today
is a best-selling author a tv host a
journalist a mother a dog lover
and a newly minted podcaster megan kelly
welcome to the reuben report
hey so good to be with you a newly
minted podcaster megan you're
dipping your toes in some new waters
we're going to talk about everything but
let's start there you're getting back in
the fight what are you not you know
i'm excited it like i thought when i
left nbc that i would just sort of
maybe i'd be skipping my new life i
would just take it easy and i would take
care of my kids which was very enjoyable
and remain so because they're at good
ages right now
and you know maybe i'd be like a lady of
leisure see how that went
and then i tuned out from the news which
was helpful
and um then you know bit by bit it
started to pull me back in
and i started to read more and more and
more and think all hell broke loose in
our country
and like the culture wars really just
make my head spin
and the one thing that really made me
want to get off the couch
um over the time that i had off was the
movie no safe spaces
and i i was glued to my chair
watching it and i cried it was and i
thought
this is i have to get back out there
they're just there aren't enough people
who are saying the things that need to
be said there's too many people who are
being silenced just for having a
dissenting voice
a reasonable but dissenting voice and if
you have the opportunity to get to a
microphone and have those discussions
you better do it so here i am
so since i was in no safe spaces can i
fully credit myself
for bringing megan kelly back into the
fight is that is that fair
you and adam and dennis and ben and
mark joseph the producer who i came to
know over the years and he's just
he's so unsung as an amazing filmmaker
you know he's doing in hollywood
what nobody else is doing which is
trying to shed a light on
some conservative causes some just even
center or center-right
uh issues and i'll just give you one
quick example dave when
i had my show on nbc he called me up and
he said i have suzette kilo
from kilo versus connecticut you know
the the case that went all the way up to
the supreme court and
and it was an eminent domain case does
the state have the ability to grab her
little pink house
even though she doesn't want him to have
it under eminent domain like they need
it
and um she she everybody
on my team was like huh right they
they weren't into it and i was like i
want her so we put her on
and mark was the connection it was the
highest rated segment we had the entire
time on nbc by far it was like that that
guy
is tapping into something you know
americans want
more stories about the little guy they
don't they don't live and breathe
hollywood celebrities and um anyway i
love mark joseph and i love
that movie and if your audience has not
seen it it's available now online and
it is so worth your two hours
yeah well you've also been through your
own version
of what we were talking about in the
movie which is the cancel thing
and the mob and and all that stuff but
you know we've gotten to know each other
a little bit
in the last year so i didn't have to do
major research to talk to you right now
but i did scribble down a couple things
here
and one of them that i wrote down was
that how you're getting back into the
fight and it's sort of like the mafia
pulling you back in
and you just said you were sort of
reeled back in by this thing
and is that sort of how you feel about
the news like
that you you love it but then also you
kind of need to escape and then
it just sucks you back in either way yes
because the thing for me is i have never
been a political person
and so i was never jazzed up just by
politics you know what i mean like
i used to look at charles krauthammer
and the way he was just he loved
politics and he wrote about it the way
like it was the most important thing
ever and as somebody who was raised sort
of non-ideological not even watching the
evening news we watched the jeffersons
um i was like you know i don't know i
like covering the news
and i like talking about politics to the
extent it's news
but not just beating up politicians and
battering around issues just to make an
hour on tv
and what happened to me was i started
watching more and more of the news and
of course we had political fights going
left and right but i was not so
interested in getting back to cover the
latest fight between george conway and
president trump at all um but the
culture wars
um what's happening in our society
what's happening legally i mean right
now it's like
this is right my wheelhouse everything
is happening with the supreme court
and just more and more like the erosion
of our freedoms
which is you know i practice law for 10
years it's
i it's a noble cause for which to fight
and you'll get called names and you'll
get beaten up and it'll be very brutal
but there are so many people who are on
your side and i'm not saying
you're against all the things that
you're talking about but you're talking
about them
you're talking about them i feel like
that that's what inspired me to get back
out here
let's talk about the jeffersons yeah
george
george would probably george would
probably be
a republican right like he was a
successful
business owner you know moved on up to
the east side he'd probably be a
republican
you're probably right he did build that
although i don't know marla gibbs
the maid i don't she was my favorite i'm
not sure she'd probably give him a hard
time for it
oh she would that was uh florence she
would definitely good
speaking of speaking of new york city
you are actually in
new york city right now what the hell is
going on in new york city right now
oh my god it's like you know to me it's
sad because i've lived here
i mean off and on i've lived here for 15
17 years
and we moved to the upper west side
because
it had become a neighborhood it had
become a safe place where you could
raise your kids and you could stroll
down the sidewalks
and with good schools and you know cute
little bodegas where you could just
go and get a bagel whatever and and
in like a year our mayor ruined it
he i mean you really have to tip your
hat to him because it's not easy to
wreck new york
but he did it and i mean we're gonna
come back i don't believe for one
second that new yorkers are going to lie
down and stay lying down
um but boy this mayor has given us quite
a quite a fight
because the city's totally different
than it was just before i left for
quarantine
i mean it's depressing it looks like
1970s new york where i came all the time
because my nana lived here
um it's like it's not even just there's
obviously a massive homeless problem on
on the upper west side in particular
where i live because he moved
he filled three hotels up here with
homeless people um without any plan
one-third of them were convicted
pedophiles and it's like well
you know maybe we could have used a
heads-up on that a plan on you know how
to
deal with it no he didn't um it's like
walking down the street and just hearing
so much profanity
which i like a good swear just as much
as anybody else but i try not to drop
them in front of my kids in front of my
seven-year-old
but vulgarity too dave it's just like
i'm gonna take the f
in this and i'm gonna do this to you you
know somebody in the cell phone
like i i'm so sad about it i feel
lost yeah you know i used to live on the
upper west
and when i've gone back over the last
couple years every time i go back i'm
like ah
it's a little worse than last time a
little worse than last time
and now i haven't been back since
lockdown but i told you my sister and
her
husband and kids they got out of there
and and it's like what kind of future
does the
does the city have do you think people
make the connection
between what's happening like on the
ground there and the fact that de
blasio's policies
are actually what cause it yeah you
think they do
100 he has such a low approval rate here
in manhattan it's under 25
i think according to the latest poll i
saw the democrats have turned on him the
republicans have never been a fan
i remember having him on my show on fox
when
he was running and he was like last in
the polls this is back when anthony
weiner was supposed to win that mayoral
race
don't get me started and um and i
remember saying
city advocate what the hell is that
nobody ever heard of you you have no
chance
and he was like i got a chance i could
do it like what do you do with city
advocate
i still don't understand um but i do
know now
he and his wife are talking about you
know layoffs and
furloughs and yet his wife still has her
140 000
a year speechwriter she's got her
videographer following her around
while the trash bins are overflowing on
the streets of new york the restaurant
owners are suffering
these mom-paw shops which are already
suffering under him i've now gone out of
business with no hope of coming back
so you know i hope she gives a really
good speech because we're all paying for
it
yeah exactly so you mentioned that the
culture war is partly what's
what's bringing you back and i remember
watching you on
on fox you know years ago and what i
liked about you was that
well you just first off some people just
know how to talk to the camera like you
just know how to do it first off was
that just always
very natural to you that you could just
be yourself just like that
no no no i would not say that i mean if
you go back and look at some of my
earliest hits on fox and i was on abc
local in dc prior to that they're very
stilted
they're they're pretty stilted you know
very
i'm right and um i i always say about
television it's like typing
the more you do the better you get the
smoother you get but you know you cannot
get to 70 words a minute without
doing 20 30 40. so i always tell the
young people who are coming up behind me
like
who want to be good on tv just practice
just say yes to every hit
there's nothing that's below you do do
it and do it often
do it even when you don't want to do it
and then one day you wake up and it's
not hard
yeah it's weird i look back and i'm like
man 20 years ago when i was like a
struggling comic i was doing you know
4 a.m radio hits and it was like i was
like willing to
absolutely do anything and i look back
and i'm like why was i doing that but i
i guess maybe it worked at some level
right yeah
it ships in the bank and honestly even
just the exercise of getting on your
feet you know like comics have that
experience which is so helpful
and i as a lawyer had that as well which
was helpful but like
you got to keep doing it that's a muscle
that needs exercise like
getting up there making your point i i
used to practice on a little phone
like i'm looking into right now and um
i i would pretend to do a television hit
you know like there was a fire down on
54th today
it was just made up it was fake news and
uh my my rule for myself was
i i couldn't stop so no matter what if i
stumble
i have to do 60 seconds on the fake fire
and it was very helpful because usually
you can stop and you can have a redo
and as you know on live television you
cannot
all right let's see how seasoned you are
right now give me 60 seconds on that
fake fire i think it's on 62nd at west
end
on 62nd and west end oh it came to a
halt today as fire trucks
came to the scene within two minutes of
the first 9-1-1 call
the blaze turned into a four-alarm fire
putting lives
at risk yet the fdny did what it always
does
saved lives and protected the community
more as we get it
back to you oh my god a true
professional you haven't lost it you
haven't lost it
so anyway so i i remember truly i
remember watching you on fox
and it was like you you had that thing
with the camera but also i think what
you said before is right like
you didn't strike me as someone that was
consumed by the political thing
and yet now it seems like everyone not
just
people in the world that we're in
everyone
everywhere sports world fashion world
doesn't matter what world you could be a
shoe shiner
you could be a you know selling you
could be working at petco it doesn't
matter what it is
everything is freaking political right
now
i know you kind of see that as as much
of a danger as i do right
yeah it's my worst nightmare it's my
worst nightmare
because what i love and one of the
reasons i love practicing law was
debating issues i like to be persuaded
i'd love to be told that i'm wrong and
then be brought over to the other side i
know you do too
um because i'm open-minded to being
wrong you know i
i always say i'ma learn it all not a
know-it-all um
and now it's just i listen to some hard
partisans you know i listen to certain
podcasts and so on
and it's interesting and it's sort of
like a tickler like this is what it's
like on this side
but i i always end up thinking i just
don't want to be that person i'm just
not at heart this hard partisan person
i'm not i wouldn't describe myself as a
moderate though because
i have strong points of view you know i
what i believe i really believe and i
feel strongly about but
i'm not kind of wishy-washy but i also
feel no
loyalty to either side i'm not i'm
certainly not a loyal democrat
i've been a registered republican but
i'm registered independent now
um i've been a registered democrat too
by the way and i just i look at these
parties and i'm like
yeah you don't represent me but
you know i'll take what i believe in
from both sides
yeah and yet everyone seems to have to
make a political statement
about everything constantly so if you
had to just if you had to describe your
political beliefs right now
like where what what is that
what are they i mean i would say i'm i'm
center-right
on a lot of issues i'm i'm center-left
on some other issues
i took a test online that says like what
are you you know
and when i literally yeah and you it
said i was a conservative republican
and i was like and then i had doug my
husband take it and it said he's a
conservative republican
and we're both independents who have
voted for democrats and republicans
you know it like throughout our lives
so i just think like the country's
moving so far left to some extent like
that
the things that used to be center left
or even center are now
right established right um so i don't
know when that happened but
i i would still vote for a democrat if i
saw the right one
you know um and i i don't know i'm
certainly not
part down the party line republican
there are a lot of them who i don't like
and i
voted against yeah so what was it like
for you to
sort of be someone that was supposed to
be talking about the news
but also for a lot of the time you were
you were kind of making news i mean
everyone knows the
what happened with trump and and the the
debate
um but that you sort of got sucked into
news too and
in the movie there's a line where um
nicole kidman as
as you basically says that you know no
no charlize theron oh
sorry uh charlie's thrown where she says
um
you know that she you basically saying
you know
you didn't want to be making the news i
assume that's pretty i didn't want to be
the story
yeah yeah i said i'm not going to be the
story and i don't want to be the story
and and i was the story after that
debate and i
hated it and i have hated being the
story every time it's happened
you know i see journalists as as
you know on the sidelines not as players
on the field
and um you know trump to some extent
grabbed me and put me on the field
and the roger ailes thing did too and
then just i don't know once you get
well known you know that the sleazy
media
takes a big interest in you and starts
following you around and
they're not all bad some guys are good
there was actually a sweet guy
right after i left nbc all these
paparazzi were outside of my apartment
and um you know i couldn't like leave
without getting
and this one guy he was from the post he
got his shot he's like
and then he goes this is such [ __ ]
megan you can't say anything anymore
so like there are real people out there
they're not all
bad but i don't like being the topic of
the news
i i have asked myself many times why
that keeps happening you know
i think i think people aren't used to
seeing like
somebody they can't figure out somebody
who's sort of
unapologetically strong um especially
especially
a woman that we're out there but like
it's not that common
and um a woman who doesn't mind fighting
right like it's like what what's she
doing
well you know that i'm futilistic by
nature and i think it
it may be exciting it may be upsetting
you know it may be alienating but for
whatever reason
it's attractive news yeah it's funny to
me because as you're getting back into
the fray like it's so
obvious there's going to be a moment
like within a couple months
where something's going to happen like
you're going to say something or one of
your guests is going to say sorry
and you're going to be like oh why did i
get back in but then but then an hour
later you'll be like this is exactly why
i got back in like that's just the
negotiation
i don't think that's going to happen to
me i mean i do think they're going to
come after me you know knives out but
i'm just so used to being attacked for
everything i say it's like
at this point i'm like all right you
know what what are you gonna do you're
gonna call me a mean name
what would that feel like what would it
feel like to see myself called something
horrible in every newspaper
in the country oh wait i've done that in
a way it's sort of empowering because
it's like
they they took their best shot i'm here
i'm well
i'm happy i'm about to launch something
that i'm really
into and for one steve like
they can't get rid of me they can't get
rid of me you know like
even if every sponsor i have is like
we're out then i'll do subscription
you know the relationship will be
between me and my audience
and they can't stop it whether they want
to or not they can't stop it i will
have my say i will have these
discussions with interesting provocative
people
people who go against the grain and if
the audience is there
i will remain on the air you're speaking
my language sister i i may be able to
retire
i may be able to retire early now that
you're getting back in
what do you mean we're going to go off
to the sunset together in the digital
sunset
the digital sunset there you go all
right so let's talk
a little bit about just like generally
what's going on in the world right now
um you know the the racism stuff
the the the riots the protests
we'll get to kobit in a sec what do you
make
about what is happening here it seems to
me that we're just sort of watching the
entire fabric
that we've had here for 200 you know
almost 50 years
basically unravel that that just sort of
this idea that this whole thing was
founded on racism
and that's the driving force behind
everything it strikes me as so
dangerous and yet it's so sort of
accepted which is kind of what you were
saying before about
uh that that the left seems to have
taken so much control of this stuff
what do you make of what's happening
right now with race and the conversation
well i think it's very frustrating for
people
like me like you who would like to be
allies
to people of color to black people
anybody who feels
ostracized and suffers from racism
and yet there's no way in without
somehow completely embracing the insane
messaging from a group like black lives
matter
i think most normal people believe there
is racism
in the country but that we are not a
racist country
and that and they don't believe we were
founded on racism and even even the new
york times with this 1619 project is
slowly
withdrawing all those names from a piece
without highlighting the withdrawal
they're just like oh never that stuff we
said about being founded on racism and
the whole point about like
you know keeping slavery never mind
eraser
which is so dishonest that's literally
happening yeah
literally for a news organization not to
call attention to the deletion that's a
massive deletion and it caused a lot of
controversy
and they're just slowly taking it down
it's not true the country wasn't founded
to hold on to slavery and it isn't a
racist country it did used to be
you know i mean back in slavery jim crow
we had massive problems
but the thing that bothers me about
what's happened over the past few months
is it's based on a lie it is based on a
lie
not the george floyd case that was
disturbing and that case will play out
appropriately in the court
but the lie that police are
systemically and as a group hunting
black people it isn't true
and even you know i think that was the
term lebron james used you know
something about how a black
person or black man can't even go
outside where they're getting hunted
wrong and the data are there and the
people who
cite the data get just so malign but if
you look like
here in new york in the 1970s the
murders per year that the
shootings uh per year were in the 400
400 plus
a couple years ago they were down to
like 36 right so it's like
they're the top behavior is going in the
right direction there are some bad
apples we all know that in any
profession there are
right certainly in our profession um
if you look at the actual data of the
number of
black unarmed men because it's always
men
uh who get killed by police uh compared
to their number of interactions with
police their crime rate
um it's not disproportionate right
because the studies will show in jason
riley of the wall street journal
who is black has been doing a great job
covering this
that over 50 of the violent crimes are
committed
by black men and that is why they have a
higher interaction rate with police in
part
and therefore the stakes go up right the
stakes go up for
because given the history between them
it's fraught
for a negative encounter and then for
potentially something deadly to happen
i'm not saying it's good
i'm just saying you can't attribute it
to racism without factoring in
crime rates yeah so
do you think that the the democrats have
sort of gone too deep
on this kind of stuff this is where you
know for someone like me that used to be
a left you know i was a lefty i was a
democrat the whole thing
where it's like every message that now
pretty much comes out
of the left is this is a racist nation
this is racism racism racism
and then the average person if you cite
any of those studies or if you read any
book by thomas soule or listen to any
talk by larry elder
they'll somehow tell you that you know
well they'll actually call those guys
sellouts or uncle toms or something else
but then even the fact that you've cited
them they'll use as proof of your racism
because you found a black person that
agrees with you and it's almost like
there's just nothing left to talk about
it
it's very depressing actually i mean i
think for you know
me and you like i don't really care like
it's fine you can call me whatever you
want to call me i'm going to say what's
true
i am going to say the facts and if you
don't like the facts
you don't have to listen to me great you
can go you want to write write up what i
said good bad or ugly go for it that's
just more exposure of my worldview
but you don't have to listen um
i i think it's more problematic for you
know
the civilians if you will right people
who don't
engage in punditry uh for a living
because they're scared
they've genuine and i would say like the
most disturbing part about
the end of my time at nbc was
the message it sent to you know the
folks on the street which is
you say one quote wrong thing
you're dead you know you're dead and
that is just not the country most of us
want to live in
you know i it really upsets me when i
see what's happening with teenagers
you know like these teenagers who are
getting their lives ruined
because they say and do stupid stuff
just like we all said and did
stupid stuff uh and no no more in
today's day and age
you're done yeah so i don't want to
rehash all the
all the past stuff in nbc and all that
but i did see uh recently when
when kim klasik who's running for uh
representative for i think it's district
seven in baltimore
she was on the view she got into it with
the ladies and
a little bit of a cat fight started and
she basically said well joy
[ __ ] enjoyed behar you know you've
been in blackface and you had a pretty
clever
tweet about the sort of double standard
on this stuff that sort of if you're a
lefty liberal
you can kind of get away with not only
being in blackface but also pretending
that the whole black community as joy
said sort of supports her
where it was a little different for you
well well i think what joey was arguing
was that she was never
in blackface because she intended her
blackface
halloween costume to be an homage
to black that's what she said it was an
homage
and you know it's funny because i i
remember people saying very clearly when
i tried to discuss this issue about
whether there could ever be an instance
where you were trying to
honor someone um where it might be
acceptable
and though all hell broke loose and so i
was waiting i was waiting to see you she
works for abc i was waiting to see
a report on um world news tonight right
uh like like they did with me
on gma like they did with me um on nbc
but
nbc was totally interested in my
comments but i didn't see lester holt
covered joy behar's comments
and yet the whole world gave a very
strong message that you may never
you homage no intense is not
relevant it's not and even just last
week chris rock was saying intent is
relevant
in talking about why he forgave jimmy
kimmel or jimmy fallon
for um playing him with black face on
so anyway i of course is a double
standard you know it's like
you got to live with it you can't just
like boo hoo but it's kind of fun to
call attention to it because
they just can't get out of it you know
what i mean the left is like the media
is so dishonest and i really make no
distinction between the left and the
media they're
other than fox and sort of declared
conservative media
there are no conservative outlets or
even center or independent outlets
they're all left so that's actually kind
of where i wanted to go next
so what do you make of just generally
like the state of journalism well first
off do you consider
cable pundits and all of the faces and
even
you know what i do and the other people
that are doing this on youtube and
everywhere else
like do you consider all of us
journalists like i don't consider myself
a journalist i'm telling people what i
think i'm interviewing people
but i'm not out in the field you know
collecting information and reporting on
it i can
i can read a story and and process it
and tell people what i think
but but i think a lot of people think
that don lemon is a journalist
like i don't consider him or chris cuomo
a journalist
or even tucker i don't consider a
journalist
do you think that even matters like what
we're calling them i think it matters i
think there's still a distinction
between journalists and pundits
and uh you know opinion journalists
that's another sort of category
um i think the problem with somebody
like lemon or cuomo is they don't
they're not honest about it
they actually think they're straight
news journalists so i'm told is rachel
maddow
she thinks she's a straight news
journalist and i've got no beef with
rachel maddow it's fine she can say what
she wants every night but let's not
pretend
it it's a fact that it's
journalistically sound it's not and you
need to look no further than her
coverage of russiagate for proof of that
um
yeah i think it's amazing that they'll
put those guys
on cnn out there at a presidential
debate as moderators trying to pawn them
off to the audience
as straight news guys you know that
they're they are not
straight news journalists they're not
and even like fox would never use tucker
for a presidential debate
but tucker he is a journalist he's got a
background in journalism but he's
morphed over to the opinion side right
but his
his background is in journalism i think
he's more over to the opinion side and
he doesn't make any
you know secret of that fox news would
never have sean hannity
sitting there anchoring a presidential
debate or at least they wouldn't have
when i was there
because they understood you got the
journalists you know like paris faulkner
and brett bear who do journalism
journalism and then you got the
appendage
journalism and then you got the opinion
folks who who are great at what they do
yeah do you think journalism can come
back
i mean you probably see me do it on
twitter all the time but every time
i have to write the word journalist or
journalism i have to put air quotes
around it because it seems
just so absolutely far gone
i don't have a lot of hopes for it i
gotta be honest i
i don't know that it can i think you
know more and more we're moving into
this
land where there's no demilitari let me
try to say that again
there's no demilitarized zone you know
it's like
people are they're forcing you to pick a
side and um
i don't think that i'm not sure people
really
even want you know crazy
sort of uncle walter he wasn't crazy but
you know what i mean like
sort of let me tell you the news anymore
i think they kind of want spin they want
a little bit of their
world view reflected and i actually
think that that's
that's why some of the fox news
journalists do so well like if you watch
brett bear's program
he understands who his audience is it is
not a newscast
that reflects what you read in the new
york times right this is what i used to
do on the kelly file
um so you understand who you're
programming too
right but then you discuss the news in a
way that's truly fair and balanced
so it's not diminishing or dismissive
of either side the way it always is if
you see
anything discussed especially cultural
issues on these other channels
like when was the last time you heard
msnbc discuss homeschooling
uh in any way other than with disgust or
the second amendment or religion in the
public square
you know they they're disgusted by
people who believe in those things and
it shows
so anyway i don't have high opportunity
i see us getting more and more partisan
and retreating to those corners
yeah look at you on the upper west the
the liberal haven
of the world and you're willing to talk
about those things
guts you know i've been i've been here
for a long time i used to um
when we first got to the upper west side
i said to my husband doug
you know do you think it's really as
liberal as they say and
at that moment this is back in 2006 i
think or whatever 2000 around there
at that moment there's a woman walking
by with a t-shirt that reads
kill cheney first like
i think i have my answer it's like you
it really is like a comedy routine you
walk down the block here and it's like
would you support greenpeace did you
support planned parenthood
did you sign this thing against trump
register to vote
you know fascist whatever it's like take
care
thank you yeah bye now it's so funny i
remember living up there and i would go
to
zabar's on sundays to grab a bagel and
locks and outside you know they'd have
those book guys outside just with the
old books
and basically every book it was when
george w bush was president
every book was like he's the devil he's
evil he's evil and i remember even
thinking back then even though i was
really
more in that line of thinking i remember
thinking something's not quite right up
here
oh my god you go into our local
bookstore like it's actually our it's a
children's store but it's got a lot of
books and the whole wall of books is
like
even before ruth bader ginsburg died it
was like rbg the notorious and
you know all michelle obama and um i
know to hillary clinton and then chelsea
clinton
and it was like you know strong women
and like i never saw condi rice
you know like they just it's
look it this is their politics and
that's fine they can have their politics
so far we've all gone along respectfully
there's a turn there's there's been a
turn where it's like
suddenly you know how it is if you're if
you're not
like a left-wing democrat these leftists
i don't think normal liberals are like
this but these leftists
are they think you're you're a racist
you're a bigot you're a xenophobe you're
a sexist and that's just
that yeah and then they start showing up
to you know people sitting having dinner
outside
and next thing you know we we got even
bigger problems
um but speaking of uh ruth bader
ginsburg so i know we are holding this
for a couple days so i don't want to get
into the
hold on while you say that i'm just
going to grab a glass of water
oh i thought you had i thought you maybe
had like a little doll of ruth bader
ginsburg or something with you i don't
know
where we're going with that um i do have
a fun song about her though if you
google it there's one on the on youtube
that goes
will you marry me ruth bader ginsburg
you're my favorite justice on the
supreme
court my son found it in doing some
homework project
there you go we've uh we've really
turned politics into something strange
uh you're gonna cut this part out aren't
you no we are not we do not
edit and i hope that the megyn kelly
show also will not edit for
are you going to edit for content we
don't we don't edit tell me that
i wouldn't said half this [ __ ]
i don't know if i if i say something
stupid i hope we take it out
we actually i don't even know the answer
that dave i haven't made a philosophical
commitment not to edit
um so we'll see we'll see the only time
actually that we edited for you know
we've edited out if someone like had a
coughing fit or something like that
only one time did we edit for content
and i don't want to say who the guest
was
but let's just say uh well i will say it
was a she
and she was extremely high and extremely
drunk
and i probably saved her career by
editing out about 45 minutes
of the interview and if someone was to
really think about it that has watched
all the reuben reports they could
probably figure it out
and i i know i'm telling you after oh
good i was
gonna say i'm gonna go back and search
all of the old ones just to find out
yeah but but speaking of uh of ruth
bader ginsburg and everything that's
going on with the supreme court right
now
you tweeted out something that i thought
was just like so you framed
it so correctly which is that's you
basically said
and you can clean it up for me but in
essence you were saying like look
everybody's sort of a hypocrite here and
you can sort of catch everybody saying
the reverse
when they're not in power but but this
is just how politics works it it just
sort of
is and i think that's what most people i
think kind of see
right now it's like we can all look back
on videos of biden saying the reverse
and harrah's saying the reverse and
mcconnell's saying the reverse like
it's across the board but then there's
also just like the reality of politics
and if you've got the power
you're going to use it these people
doing
jiu jitsu to try to say mcconnell
isn't changing anything you know because
what he
what he said at one time but not in all
the other interviews was that when it's
when it's divided government when it's
like a sitting democrat
in the white house and the republicans
and then now that the senators are
coming out like well here's all the
numbers through the number of times that
look it's a reversal by the republicans
but
crimea river for the democrats who are
upset over it because
they are the ones who started this
judicial war i've been following the
court for a long time and practicing law
for a long time too
and this started back when they borked
robert prior to that the standard was to
confirm
any reasonable jurist you you knew
republican
presidents were going to pick
conservative leaning justices uh
democratic ones were going to pick more
liberal-leaning ones and in the end it
balances out
then then robert came up and they said
no way
he's too conservative he's not getting
on and that that was the first time that
changed
and then miguel estrada who was
a star lawyer who they wanted to elevate
the republicans wanted him
um on this dc circuit court of appeals
and the democrats were quoted as saying
they were they were afraid of him
because
he was this dynamic um hispanic
rising star in the republican party and
they didn't want him because they knew
he'd make the supreme court someday and
they held up his nomination
his confirmation hearings for two years
to the point where the guy finally had
to say i
i withdraw like i gotta get on with my
life support my family
they started that and that's why
later mitch mcconnell started to slow
roll barack obama's judges
that led to harry reid saying i'm doing
the nuclear option
screw you we're getting rid of the
filibuster the
republicans stood up and said if you get
rid of the filibuster on lower court
judges we're going to do the same to you
on supreme court judges if we ever take
power in the senate again
then the american electorate put the
republicans in charge of the senate and
mitch mcconnell was true to his word
i mean it's it ain't beanbag right and
it's
ugly and it's gonna get even uglier i i
don't predict
anything kind or good happening over the
next
six months when it comes to the supreme
court yeah
do you sense there's any way we can get
out of this thing i mean putting aside
whether it's just about supreme court
just like
everything that everyone feels so crazy
all the time that politics is everywhere
all the time
that it seems like half the people want
to burn it down and
the other the other half according to
them are all racists anyway like
do you see a path to getting out of it
i sadly i think the only thing that
would do it anytime soon is some sort of
national
tragedy you know and i don't mean like
proven i mean
a war you know um obviously i'm not
wishing for that i'm just saying
it takes something truly massive like
that to
bring the country together and as tough
as corona has been it too has been
politicized
and it hasn't had the horrific shock
value
you know in an instant the way say a 911
did or i'm sure pearl harbor did
where you're just like holding on to
humanity and looking at your fellow
human beings with a little bit more
kindness
um i don't know i've often thought okay
trump is definitely such an unusual
leader
right and he's divisive of course but i
don't think this goes away
if donald trump loses this election i
think trump was
definitely a a a result
of our increasing partisanship and um
you know the republicans wanted and
needed a fighter
and they're not really concerned that he
doesn't speak the queen's english
and isn't necessarily you know the
perfect husband and you know
he's he's had some moral failings of
course um
so i don't think even if he if he's gone
whether it's joe biden or somebody else
another even another republican in the
office
it gets better until we're reminded of
what matters
what why do these people have so much
time and i can say this because i'm a
woman
to focus on their gender right like why
how they're being discriminated against
as a woman
how like i know they'll say because
we are you know we're victims i don't
believe that
because i have other women to talk to
and i have other black
men to talk to and i have other trans
friends to talk to
who don't run around looking for ways in
which they've been victimized all day
every day
they're strong they lead their lives
they suffer some adversity like we all
do
time to time they forge forward they
take life lessons from it they move on
like the amount of navel gazing that
goes on in figuring out
what identity do i have that will allow
me to
embrace the victim ideology is a total
waste of time
yeah well it's miserable it won't get
you anywhere and look
even for you it's not that being a woman
in the news business is the easiest
thing i mean
bombshell is sort of is sort of about
that
um but you pretty much just kept moving
forward
and it basically worked well i don't
i've never liked to think of myself as a
victim and
i recognize that doesn't mean i i've
never been one right like
i i had i had a terrible stalker a
felonious
stalker in my life who went to prison
for a very long time after he stalked me
and um and i have been bullied by some
very powerful
figures but i never call myself a victim
i always call myself a target right like
i was a target of that stalker and i was
target of
certain people and that's fine i can get
past that
like eventually you're not a target
anymore and
if the more like you get ensconced
in that woe is me ideology even if
you deserve it even if you do deserve
empathy and you have been victimized
the worse it is for you you know it just
leads to a constant cyclone of
negativity
sadness anger around you
and you you've got to as a gift to
yourself pull yourself out of that
i don't know i don't care if it's
cognitive behavioral therapy where you
just got to think of a picture of your
dog
like do do whatever you need to do to
get yourself out of that
when you don't it leads to bad things in
your life your happiness level goes down
not
up right if you just think of yourself
as victimized all the time
so i don't i don't understand why more
people don't get that
i think people are sort of looking for a
reason to feel victimized
to find their posse you know like to
feel like they're bonded
to other people in the same position i
think this is why
women get mad at me when i won't say i'm
a feminist you know they want me in the
posse and they don't get my
stiff arm on some of their favorite
words uh but i find the other the
opposite
world view much more conducive to
success
yeah your your kids are pretty young but
do you sense that
ideology leaking into their world either
through school
or whatever messages they're getting or
friend groups whatever it is
very much so and doug and i are really
trying to counter program that
you know it's like my my son yates went
into school this this past year last
year
one of his best friends is black his
parents are friends of ours
and these two guys are just buddies you
know they're just buddies they just hang
out they have play dates
and by the end of the year you know the
messaging to the black child was
basically you've been oppressed
your your parents your ancestors have
been oppressed since the beginning of
time
and the message to my son was and you
are the oppressor
and they're sewing they're sewing
division where none existed
these are just sweet boys who love to be
with each other
like and and by the way this other
little boy's parents
didn't appreciate that either it wasn't
you know a white black thing it was just
a divisive thing that doesn't help
anybody
um i've it's been painful to me you know
it's really been painful to watch
because
i i see like my daughter's best friend
is
um she's black she's her mother is white
her
her father's black so she's mixed race
but
they they don't see color these girls
they they go out they do fun things
you know yardley wouldn't even remark on
this girl's
skin coloring in describing her to
anybody but
all around us people are trying to make
her notice
to know that there's a difference
between them and that it's
awful and that you know one person's
distant distant distant relatives or
maybe not even their relatives but just
people who have the same color skin did
something awful
to you know people who share the other
skin color
and i just i don't see i don't see how
that's helping i i believe much more in
the martin luther king dream of seeing
the two
you know the black kid and the white kid
walking down the street holding holding
hands because it was happening
it's still happening yeah well i know
you know this but according to critical
race theory it's not enough
to be not racist you have to be actively
anti-racist so your daughter not
seeing color they would argue i mean
this is in the critical race theory
literature like they would literally
argue that that in and of itself is
racism because that status quo upholds
the structure
by itself i mean i think the only
response to that is
fight me it's absurd
and if you're listening to that nonsense
good luck
you can't have an honest conversation if
it begins like that
yeah speaking of uh nonsense we we
talked a little bit about trump and you
know you
you were obviously in the midst of it
with him at some level and and the
fights and the media and all that stuff
what do you make of the biden situation
do you think he's okay
i mean obviously he's struggling with
the effects of old age
to put it charitably you can see it
there's there's really no denying it
and um it does at times feel like the
democrats are really just trying to get
him over the finish line like did you
see the woman
the liberal woman when she heard that
rbg died and she sent out this video
it's spectacular and she's like
you had one thing to do you just had to
get through to january of 2012
or 2021 she was so upset i think that's
kind of how a lot of democrats are
looking at biden like
just stfu and get him over the finish
line just
get him to just shut up it's not
happening
no one gives a damn that he can't put
the words together like he's gonna sign
the right laws
harris is gonna make him and we'll be
fine like he's
a hell of a lot better than you know
scary orange man
that's how they see it right um and i do
wonder whether it would be a harris
administration either
secretly or you know soon if biden wins
doesn't that seem like such a bizarre
plan though because i'm i'm kind of with
you that i think that was the plan
but they didn't expect him to break down
this quickly and i don't even know who i
mean by they
because it's like who are they are we
talking about the dnc or are we talking
about like
the clinton machine or whatever that is
but i think they didn't expect that the
collapse
his sort of mental state was going to
just collapse so quickly
but then doesn't it seem odd that they
would choose kamala harris who was
polling at like three percent within her
own party
and was out way faster than many of the
other candidates like it just all seems
so bizarre
i think this is you know they're very
committed
to identity in in the democratic party
you know and again i do make a
distinction like some of my best friends
are democrats
they don't think about this [ __ ] like
they don't think about any of this like
they're
so what makes them what makes them
democrats then at this point because
that's what i'm trying to figure out
because you know i have those friends
too that's the world so like what kind
of issue is is like a sensible
democratic issue to you
like what would they say no so my duke
my two best friends in the world
live in the midwest one lives in detroit
and one lives in chicago
and one's a dam and one's a republican
and my my democrat friend
you know she's pro-choice she's
pro-obamacare
um she's pro-environment um
she's i want she doesn't mind
expansive government right she thinks
the government has a meaningful role to
play in helping the poor and the
underprivileged
um but when it comes to these cultural
issues she's kind of like oh stop it
stop it you know like we're all normal
we don't even need to obsess about this
stuff
and it's not just you know race it's
like race and gender and
all the stuff all the isms that people
are latching on to right now
and i would say my my republican friend
there is kind of the reverse of her on
some of those issues
but lands in the same spot and and
just when i think of my democratic
friends they're like her
they're like my friend in detroit
they're not obsessed with this stuff
but the left has gotten so loud
and they've gotten control of such large
and important cultural institutions
that they're they're having their way
you know they're having their way and i
know like douglas murray's been saying
that's why people need to speak up you
know the silent majority needs to speak
up
and i realize easier said than done
given the canceled culture we're in
but until we get to the point where
people stand up and say
i'm not going to let you do that to my
child or i'm not going to let you do
that to me
i'm not going to let you he says you
should stand up at your workplace that's
trying to make you swallow critical race
theory and say i will i refuse to allow
you to re-racialize
my my company my city myself
but man that's gonna take guts yeah
there's uh since you mentioned douglas
one of his best lines is he says one day
the barbarians will be at the gate
and we'll debate we'll be debating what
gender pronouns to call them
and i think that's just like it's such a
perfect summation of the whole thing
like there are real
problems out there and instead we've
decided to
debate gender pronouns and that's not to
be dismissive of trans people
i mean you have to say that because
you're worried they're going to come for
you you know what i mean it's like
i have i have such a long record of
standing up for trans people i
i have a trans person in my family um
i i got nothing against trans people but
the trans people i know
they they're upset by the hard
vitriolic responses the trans community
has
when you don't want to change the
spelling of women you know they're like
what the
and it's like who are these trans
activists who do they who are they
speaking for because
you know there's a there's a a trans
woman in my family
she wants to be called a woman she
doesn't want a different
an ex in the name she doesn't want you
to she doesn't have to declare her
pronouns
the whole point of transitioning over
was right so it's like and i realize not
everybody feels that way
but like the people who speak the
loudest would have you believe they're
they're this is how it has to be there's
any divergence if there's any discussion
of you know the monopoly of choices and
the consequences you're bad that isn't
true
yeah yeah all right i want to uh i want
to finish up by talking about your
podcast a little bit and what what
you're going to be doing
and i think i'm going to be on one of
the first episodes i hope i don't
[ __ ] it up for you that would that would
me too that would be pretty terrible
uh but real quick because we only
mentioned covent for just a second and
since you're
in new york and i'm in la so these are
two of the sort of most locked down
places with
you know mayors that uh seem to be more
than happy to keep us in this perpetual
state forever
um what's your basic take about covid at
this point like what should we be doing
should trump have done more can we just
leave it up to the states
are we ever going to end all this the
whole shebang megan kelly
well we're definitely going to end it
all we are not not
that sounds ominous it's all going to
end this crazy
will it will end um and i think it'll
end
you know relatively soon because i do
think they'll find a vaccine
people will take it um that'll calm the
nerves they're getting better at
treating it
that's good you know we're making
progress we have some of the best
medical minds in the world
in the united states and they're all
working on it and outside the united
states too
um you know i'm i'm torn on this because
we've lost people we love to covet and i
know it is it's real
you know it's real it can be brutal um
but you know
there's also an overreaction that's
kicked in that's
gotten kind of out of hand you know and
i look at my seven-year-old who
thankfully is in school
but all day with the math at recess has
to run with the mask on and
i i'll take it and we'll do it because
i'm grateful that the teachers are there
and this is the price we pay for getting
into school
but i don't think it's necessary i i
don't think i think that's too much and
i think
you know walking around new york city
you have to have a mask on
on the sidewalk i i don't think that's
necessary i think if you can socially
distance on the sidewalk
you're fine you know i think we have to
find a way of
going through the crisis instead of just
trying to go around it there's just
we're not going to permanently be able
to go around it and i just think the
massive economic destruction that's
happened
has been downplayed or ignored or mocked
in a way that's also really hurtful i
look at my
favorite restaurateurs here who are
really struggling and you know we make
donations but it's teaspoons in the
ocean
that's not gonna do it um and you know
just sort of a collective
shoulder strug shrug so i guess my
overall take is
i wish we had found a way to protect the
vulnerable
uh you know seniors people people who
are immunocompromised
um and to forge forward more robustly
um earlier on so that we could have
staved off some of the economic pain
um i think the you know the the deaths
then the numbers should be lower but
they were coming you know trump didn't
invent this virus
they were coming it's a thing and
unfortunately it has its
favorite targets and those people need
to be really careful you know really
careful and some of them i love
i have my family um anyway so that's
sort of a meandering answer but
it's a it's a complicated issue and i
think people who are like
open back up no math that's it i think
that's too extreme
right but i think um shut down stay
shut down you know no restaurants no
schools mass everywhere
that seems too hysterical to me yeah
what do you think about just like the
social cost like one of the things that
i think about a lot
is that the fact that we're all wearing
masks like
if i go to the supermarket now i'm
usually in a baseball cap
sunglasses and a mask so in effect you
can't see any part of my face which at
some level
it's nice because sometimes people come
up to me and that way i can be like
totally
anonymous which is nice but like we we
sort of don't look at each other anymore
you know what i mean like even if you
don't have sunglasses on this thing that
you can't read someone's face
i noticed that this a lot with cashiers
like because i really do try to it's one
of the things that i really worked on in
august when i was off the grid of just
like
all my interactions being as like
valuable as they could even just
with with random people but like even
cashiers like you no longer no one
smiles you don't see smiles anymore
and i'm worried that that when you then
add social media to it how we're all on
our computers all day
and our phones and then you take away
like another part of the human
element that that's like leading us to
something else that's seriously
dangerous
you you've been off the upper west side
for too long because no one smiles at
you here in new york i haven't noticed a
single difference
if you're the one smiling at everybody
you weird you're weak yeah you're the
weird guy
so it's been no problem at all we're
just sort of holding steady here
i don't know i think um the problem is
much bigger than you just
pointed out i think you know you hit on
it a bit which is technology and how
that's dividing us
and we've willingly signed on to those
kinds of lies for too long i am a
convinced that a backlash is coming
that the iphone will be put down by
millions of people because it's done a
ton of damage
especially to our kids and i think you
know the loss of the bowling league and
the church groups and you know sort of
the the clubs
um has been a real loss to america
because it's loss of connection and
caring
and you know willingness to take care of
one's neighbor when he falls
um you know the mask i don't know it's
temporary and i think people get over
it's kind of annoying
um my friend was saying she was upset
because her son has
acne and and it's aggravating the acne
and all i could think back to
was my high school years when i i had
bad acne and i would have loved a mask
you would
be like oh it's the same thing to do
the gras the grass is always greener all
right well i think
i think we got a sense of it but uh what
is the megyn kelly show gonna be about
you're doing this thing
you're doing three days a week is that
right yeah we're gonna start with three
and see how that goes
and it's gonna start not with audio
we're just gonna not with the uh
video we're gonna start with only audio
which i think will be kind of fun you
know it's like i had the microphone
the headphones on the other day and it
just felt kind of cool it just
feels pretty cool to be in charge um so
that
i i want to do what people like you are
doing dave you know i want to have
open honest conversations about tough
issues
and be fearless in doing it i really do
and i think
one good thing you know for for better
for worse
about being me is i for whatever reason
they tend to write a lot of headlines
about my news coverage
and that's good right that's good
because i want people to come on the
show and get headlines
i want people to start seeing that it's
okay to talk about the difficult issues
and in fact if you actually want
any buy-in you got to let the people
weigh in um
and just do it fearlessly and
relentlessly that's what i want to do
all right well we are going to put a
link to the megan kelly show podcast
right below and megyn kelly
like a true broadcast professional i'm
going to let you sign off
this episode of the reuben report take
us home
this is megyn kelly reporting live on
the dave reuben show
see you next time if you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful conversations
about the media instead of non-stop
yelling check out our media playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics check out the
full episode playlist
they're both right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell